All right, it is time for "Drew's news",
your fresh and fluffy news waffle covered
in that gooey, good news syrup.
And with me at the desk
is the sweetest man in town, Rossi Ross Mathews.
Hi, now I want a waffle.
When the butter gets in the crevice, and I know.
I know, sometimes, I want it really savory
so I like a lot of butter.
Oh please, yeah,
well, you know when the butter gets in the little,
oh, let go my ego girl, that's mine.
I know, Rossi, what day is it today?
It's pop quiz, hey!
(audience cheer and clap)
Pay attention, one member of our studio audience
is gonna be put to the test.
We're gonna ask you, you, or you three questions
about today's show.
And if you get it right, you're gonna take home $1,000.
(audience cheer and clap)
Yes, so get out here.
Whatever it takes.
Sometimes I like to picture a little spiral notebook
and a number two pencil, just a metaphor of the mind.
Just be taking notes all day.
Well, I'm very excited about this first story.
Okay, so check this out you guys.
There is a fascinating new documentary headed
to Netflix on April 27th.
And we have got an exclusive first look.
"The Evening Standard" reports that,
"The mystery of Marilyn Monroe,
"the unheard tapes will explore Marilyn's final days
"and uncover new information.
And they are using previously unheard audio recordings
from people who knew her well.
So take a listen and a look.
To get to people with information
about the night Marilyn died, it was difficult.
Let it be
I can't say anything.
And I knew it all.
I did what you always have to do
if you meet a dead end.
I went back to the beginning.
♪ I wanna be loved by you ♪
♪ Just nobody else but you ♪
(audience cheer and clap)
Okay, fixed already, completely.
Well, and then later this year,
Netflix is also releasing
their highly anticipated biopic "Blonde"
with Ana de Armas, and she's playing Marilyn.
And the movie just got some headlines
because it got an NC17 rating.
Hi, I really wanted to watch before and now I'm like,
"I can't wait to watch it."
Well, I have to say, I read the director's quote
in reaction to the curfuffle of people going NC17.
And he said, and I quote,
"If the audience doesn't like it,
"that's the freaking audience's problem.
"I'm not running for public office.
(laughs) Okay.
And yet I'm like, oh in these days,
you can run for public office
so don't you worry about that.
I am so excited.
What does sort of intrigue me about the Marilyns
and the Elvises is, does it always have to get so tragic?
Do we love that about them?
Do they have to reach those points?
Is there anyone that we sort of accolade
that is a healthy human being?
I don't know.
But these figures,
they just are larger than life.
And I want to kind of understand how they felt
and what they went through and what is it like
to be that adored?
Clearly, it's not an easy space to live in.
Yeah, and with these tapes of her,
maybe we'll get some of those answers.
Yes, yes, yeah.
(upbeat music)